you know in my private meeting with
president zielinski after the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots and fourth generation
fighter aircraft including f-16s to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself we provided the
last year all that they needed to deal
with what they were dealing with at the
moment and that's when now we're moving
in the direction of putting him in
position to be able to be defend
themselves in ways beyond what they've
had to deal with so far and this morning
I once more shared and assured president
zielinski together with all G7 members
and our allies and partners around the
world that we will not waver
Putin will not break our resolve as he
thought he could two years ago almost
three years ago